So far we've talked about a lot of
numbers, both positive and negative, and
our world of numbers is looking pretty
great. Still, we've really only been
counting by ones, whether above or below
0. This might be a problem however.
Thinking back to your famous birthday
party, what if your friend had baked a few
cakes instead of making a ton of cupcakes?
If you asked someone how much cake they
wanted and they only knew about integers,
they would have to say that they either
wanted no cake at all, or they wanted 1
whole cake, or maybe even 2 entire cakes.
This doesn't seem very practical and
you'll also run out of cake very quickly.
You would probably want to cut each cake
into slices and then give each person just
a piece of the cake. Let's say that you
cut 1 of the cakes into 8 pieces. If you
gave 5 friends each 1 of those slices, how
much of that cake would be left over?